il est de rouge fluo moyens il a une
forme régulière un épiderme lice il est
beau à voir
c'est le piment d'espelette on est au
marché jean-talon pensant faisait
demander beaucoup de piment gueule un
possible de cultiver du piment
d'espelette ailleurs qu'au pays basque
en france c'est une appellation
d'origine protégée par l'union
européenne depuis 2012
par contre michel et victoire palardy
cultive depuis sept ans du piment gorria
de type 10 paulette il ya eu nos amis
qui connaissait quelqu'un qui a possédé
puis qui nous en a amené un lot un
boulot quand on s'est dit on va
l'essayer pour les chefs grigori paul
c'est un assaisonnement dont il ne peut
se passer quand la décide de faire une
petite pas rien d'acquis et va être un
mix de fruits de mer grillé et à la
plancha qui vont accompagner notre
confie de piment d'espelette ferait
plonger les coquillages sur la plaque
si le flétan c'est très important de
mettre le piment d'espelette soit en fin
de cuisson fait mais pas l'utiliser dans
la cuisson pas le faire caraméliser
parce qu'il m'a brûlée de suite on va
perdre tout le parfait et ça se sent des
piments que vous avez laissé mais
j'attends c'est ça exactement en fait
c'est le piment quand il est frais pour
la cuisiner avec un petit peu de tomates
oignons huile d'olive
[Musique]
le
tous
allez un petit peu de piment d'espelette
tout ceci faut être généreux et le
piment d'espelette s'éclipser c'est le
produit qui pas forcément très épicé et
qui est très chaud bien l'huile d'olive
vierge est un petit peu de jus de citron
je pense qu'on va pouvoir les déguster
ça ensemble
grégory sait comment attirer notre oeil
ici je me suis amusé avec quelques
légumes avec une trempette une base de
yogourt piment d'espelette frais et sec
il a invité son ami pierre importateur
de vins et basques de par son père pour
célébrer le piment d'espelette
la particularité du piment d'espelette
c'est que quand on cuisine gris
évidemment il ya des sucres qui vont
sortir automatiquement et le piment
d'espelette ça n'est pas moi c'est pas
un canapé lyon c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose qui va exposer deux on va
dire de force qui va vous qui va vous en
bus à la bouche et des papilles c'est un
piment qui va tout simplement avoir un
goût un petit peu poivrot n'est pas trop
et qui ensuite va avoir une épice a pas
pire que le poivre les palardy sont
parmi les plus importants producteurs de
piment gorria au québec
je le fais sécher une fois au fond de
cette ligne complètement le séchage
personne lâche plus le monde il paie 8
kilos de piment pour produire un kilo de
poudre
mais là c'est ce que vous avez utilisé
pour préparer les plats où vous avez
utilisé le piment tous bords y a moi
j'utilise le piment gurria parce que on
est au québec
hu à l'arrière c'est en amérique du sud
que l'on trouve les plus anciennes
racines de piment d'espelette et ces
deux là aussi que nous vient la main
d'oeuvre pour le cultiver laquelle de
télésanté
soul house à bruxelles m
[Musique]
pierre vesperini a choisi des vins
rouges pour accompagner le festin ce que
génial là dedans c'est que le poivron va
permettre de boire du rouge et non pas
du blanc c'est que l'intéressé d'avoir
des vins épicés ou des vins doux et
soyeux à boire c'est pas compliqué le
rincer on aime ou on n'aime pas bien
avant de boire du vin rouge avec le
piment pierre en consommer comme remède
aux maux ma grand mère célibataire en
hiver à l'école elle me faisait un
chocolat chaud quand à savais que
j'avais là là on va dire un petit peu
mal de fond de gorge m est toujours au
youtube mais moi aussi mais elle faisait
un petit chocolat chaud avec du piment
d'espelette
pour bien tenir ce repas ont parfait
moussy les desserts avec le pima mais
comme la touch de poivrons mais tout
doux ses pieds le mix est vraiment en
fait surtout venance la framboise qui va
prendre un petit peu aussi je le fus le
fruit en goûte à maria callas quand
toujours au mur mérite au 1
[Musique]